et pour en parler nous sommes avec
gérard vespière fondateurs du web
magazine le monde décrit fait concevoir
merci d'être avec nous recep tayyip
erdogan qui a renouvelé ce jeudi son
offre d'accueillir un sommet réunissant
donc l ukraine et la russie lgv se poser
en médiateur crédible c'est une
possibilité selon vous oh oui tout à
fait parce que voyez vous depuis
quelques temps nous avions avec monsieur
erdogan un homme de tension est un homme
d'action militaire en syrie en libye en
irak très récemment avec et aux côtés de
l'azerbaïdjan contre l'arménie donc en
se mettant dans les habits du médiateur
est vide et là il se prend à mettre dans
un rôle tout à fait positif cette
fois-ci non pas dans un rôle
antagonistes et cela fait soudainement
un avantage pour lui vis-à-vis de ses
interlocuteurs européens par exemple
donc il va avoir éminemment besoins et
de votre reportage qu'il faisait
allusion parce que dans un peu moins
d'un an et demi et bien il ya des
élections en turquie et il aura besoin
d'un appui international parce que à
l'intérieur de la turquie la situation
est difficile pour lui politiquement et
économiquement
alors c'est un petit peu une position
d'équilibriste qu'il a ce président turc
un allié de l'ukraine la proche de
l'otan est proche de la russie également
tout à fait c'est pour ça qu'ils se
lancent dans cette opération parce qu'il
est déjà un interlocuteur reconnu par
vladimir poutine ce pas combien de quoi
se sont ils rencontrés à sotchi sur les
affaires iraniennes ou sur les affaires
syriennes donc il y à un canal de
communication très ouvert et il est
aussi un interlocuteur de volodymyr donc
il ya vladimir poutine a coûté et
volodymyr et l'instit de l'autre en
ukraine a à qui il fournit de l'armement
donc il est l'homme qui peut créer un
dialogue et c'est pour ça qu'ils se
proposent c'est effectivement très
habile il est sûr de pouvoir en tirer
quelque chose
justement êtes vous sûr qu'il peut en
tirer quelque chose vous dites il est
sûr d'en tirer quelque chose mais on ne
va pas peut-être l'exhorté d'une
certaine manière à choisir son camp
vous savez dans quelque chose il ya de
contenu il ya d'abord il ya l'apparence
et la réalité est donc dans l'apparence
dans ce costume dont on parlait il ya
quelques instants de médiateur et bien
le fait de pouvoir s'inscrire de pouvoir
se revêtir de ce costume de médiateur
pour lui c'est déjà un grand avantage
par rapport à son image antérieures sur
la scène internationale donc il devient
l'homme de la médiation l'homme du
respect et donc il a là une carte à
pouvoir monnayer entre guillemets
vis-à-vis de la tortue l'éditeur
européen par exemple donc il a
économiquement besoins et politiquement
besoin en tout cas va venir petit les
reproches en avoir fourni à kiev des
drones armés utilisé contre les
séparatistes pro-russes de l'est de
l'ukraine c'est quelque chose qui qui va
passer ça parce qu'on on sait déjà que
par le passé il ya eu un parfois des
bras de fer entre les deux hommes
tout à fait et je pense que ça aussi
c'est positif parce que vladimir poutine
est un homme qui manie volontiers les
rapports de force et qui acceptent d'une
certaine façon que ses interlocuteurs et
aussi de très bonnes cartes est aussi
une position de force on se rappelle des
discussions très difficiles quand
l'armée de l'air turque a abattu un
chasseur russe n'est ce pas au tout
début de l'action à des troupes russes
en syrie eh bien il ya eu des difficiles
passage à des négociations pour remettre
le train sur les rails très compliqué eh
bien voyez les choses se sont faites
donc il y à a des possibilités de
dialogue et de connexions entre les deux
leaders entre un monsieur erdogan et
vladimir poutine merci gérard vespière
fondateurs du web magazine le monde
décrypté de nous avoir apporté votre
analyse